Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Secondo voi, quali sono i componenti
fondamentali di un'orchestra?
Io penso che siano tre:
prima di tutto abbiamo bisogno
degli strumenti;
in secondo luogo abbiamo bisogno
dei musicisti,
di qualcuno che suoni gli strumenti,
come ad esempio del violinista che,
premendo l'archetto
sulle corde del violino,
permette di far uscire
la musica dallo strumento.
Ma penso che queste due cose
non bastino:
non bastano gli strumenti
e non bastano i musicisti,
ci vuole una terza componente,
che è il maestro.
Se non ci fosse il maestro, i musicisti
andrebbero per la loro strada
e verrebbe fuori un gran baccano.
È necessario avere
un maestro da seguire,
in modo che tutti questi strumenti
vadano insieme nell'orchestra.
Io lavoro in una specie di orchestra.
I musicisti sono le collisioni di protoni
prodotte dal Large
Hadron Collider, l'LHC;
e gli strumenti sono
gli esperimenti costruiti
lì dove le collisioni avvengono.
Noi non produciamo musica,
anche se c'è qualcuno
che si è divertito
a prendere i nostri dati,
qualche scienziato
ha preso i nostri dati
e li ha trasformati in musica
- ma no, io non faccio musica,
anche se mi piacerebbe.
Quello che facciamo noi
è andare a studiare
i componenti fondamentali della materia,
andare a capire come questi
interagiscono tra di loro,
come si comportano.
E ci sono molte cose che della natura
ancora non capiamo
e il nostro studio è volto a capire
come la natura funziona.
E uno dei risultati di queste ricerche
è stato, ad esempio,
trovare il famoso bosone di Higgs,
e spero di spiegarvi nel seguito
e farvi capire che cos'è,
perché è così importante.
La grande orchestra in cui io lavoro
sta a Ginevra, in Svizzera, al CERN.
Il CERN è il Centro Europeo
per la Ricerca Nucleare.
È stato fondato nel 1954,
per cui nel secondo dopoguerra,
quando gli stati europei avevano appena
smesso di farsi la guerra
e hanno cercato di ricollaborare insieme
fondando questo centro.
L'Italia è stata uno
dei 12 paesi fondatori
e adesso il CERN conta
20 paesi membri europei
e anche altri 60 stati
circa, non europei,
che partecipano alle ricerche.
Questo è il luogo dove sta l'orchestra,
ma abbiamo detto: chi produce la musica?
Chi produce la musica
è l'LHC, Large Hadron Collider,
grande collisionatore di adroni.
Questo acceleratore di particelle
è un acceleratore circolare,
lungo 27 chilometri,
che è stato costruito in un tunnel,
che qui vedete nell'immagine,
a 100 metri di profondità,
e in questi tubi blu
vengono accelerati i protoni
che poi vengono fatti collidere,
cioè vengono fatti scontrare
in quattro punti dell'acceleratore;
e in questi quattro punti
dell'acceleratore
sono stati costruiti grandi strumenti
per vedere i prodotti
delle collisioni dei protoni,
e questi quattro grossi strumenti
si chiamano ALICE, ATLAS, LHCb e CMS.
E io, in particolare, lavoro su ATLAS.
ATLAS sta per "A Toroidal LHC ApparatuS",
che significa che è una macchina
che sta all'LHC ed è toroidale.
Cosa vuol dire toroidale
lo scopriremo più avanti.
Io ho iniziato a lavorare
su questo esperimento
esattamente sette anni fa,
nel dicembre del 2006,
per la mia tesi specialistica.
Perché sono finita lì?
Mentre studiavo fisica all'Università,
ho fatto un corso di Fisica Nucleare
a cui mi sono molto appassionata,
e in questo corso
studiavamo come si comportano
i fondamenti della materia,
come si comportano le particelle
e come queste interagiscono tra loro.
E lì ho imparato che ci sono
delle regole matematiche
che tutte le particelle seguono,
per cui data la formula matematica
potete capire,
potete dedurre come le particelle
interagiranno tra di loro.
A me questo sembrava fenomenale,
che noi potessimo andare
a conoscere la natura
così in profondità
e con così tanta precisione.
Ma l'altra cosa
che mi impressionava tantissimo
e mi interessava ancora
di più era il fatto
che più studiavo, più capivo
che ci sono un sacco di cose
che queste formule matematiche,
quelle che conosciamo, ancora
non spiegano, come la materia oscura;
oppure, dieci anni fa,
quando io studiavo quelle cose,
si sapeva che il bosone di Higgs
era probabile che esistesse,
ma non si era ancora visto,
per cui io studiavo cose
che in qualche modo, prima o poi,
avremmo potuto vedere
e io volevo essere lì,
io volevo essere una
di quelle che diceva,
Ah, l'abbiamo visto, lo abbiamo trovato,
lo sapevamo che c'era, eccolo!
Ma non sono da sola
a lavorare su questo esperimento.
Siamo - ATLAS è una collaborazione
di 3000 persone
che vengono da 38 paesi diversi,
e una cosa molto interessante
è il fatto che
il 20% di queste 3000 persone
hanno molta vitamina D
e se andiamo a guardare
le persone sotto i 30 anni -
io non sono più tra quelle,
però ci sono anche persone
sotto i trent'anni
nel nostro esperimento -
il 30% ha vitamina D,
che è una percentuale abbastanza alta
se pensate alla fisica, tendenzialmente
ritenuta un luogo per uomini.
In questa mappa potete vedere
quali paesi partecipano all'esperimento.
Ad esempio, io adesso lavoro
per un'Università americana,
la Boston University,
quindi in teoria dovrei stare in America
e ad esempio il mio fidanzato
lavora per l'Università di Taiwan,
che sta esattamente
dall'altra parte del globo,
per cui sarebbero
12 ore di fuso orario.
Però lavoriamo tutti e due a Ginevra,
per cui non abbiamo molte difficoltà
- per sentirci, perlomeno.
Dunque, com'è fatto questo esperimento,
perché abbiamo bisogno
di strumenti diversi?
Se pensate all'orchestra
vi è facile pensare:
pensate ad un'orchestra senza violini,
cosa sarebbe una
sinfonia senza violini?
Si capisce che mancherebbe qualcosa.
Per un esperimento
di fisica delle particelle
funziona esattamente alla stessa maniera.
In natura esistono
diversi tipi di particelle
e servono diversi strumenti
per vedere queste particelle,
per cui se un esperimento
non ha un certo strumento,
ad esempio per vedere gli elettroni,
noi con quell'esperimento
gli elettroni non li vedremo.
Per cui è importante,
quando si progetta un esperimento,
mettere degli strumenti
che ci permettano di guardare
tutte le particelle possibili.
Ora, come è fatto ATLAS?
ATLAS è stato costruito in una caverna,
a 100 metri di profondità,
lì dove i protoni si scontrano.
Ha un diametro di 25 metri
e ha una lunghezza di 46 metri.
Queste sono le dimensioni di metà
della cattedrale di Notre-Dame a Parigi.
Il peso di ATLAS è di 7000 tonnellate.
Se vogliamo stare a Parigi,
la struttura metallica della Tour Eiffel
pesa 7000 tonnellate,
per cui è una roba veramente immensa.
In queste immagini potete forse
scorgere degli omini;
ecco, quegli omini sono in scala.
L'esperimento su cui lavoro io
è grande così.
Ma com'è fatto, e quali sono
gli strumenti che lo compongono?
Avrete visto che ha una struttura
abbastanza cilindrica,
mi piace pensarlo un po' come una cipolla,
una cipolla che ha diversi strati
e ogni strato serve a vedere
delle particelle diverse.
Ecco, qui avete uno spaccato
di come è fatto l'esperimento:
ci sono diversi strati, e ogni strato
serve a vedere qualcosa di diverso.
Ad esempio, c'è un sistema interno,
quello più vicino
al punto dove si scontrano i protoni,
che è il sistema di tracciamento;
e io sono particolarmente
affezionata a quello,
perché ci ho lavorato
per la mia tesi,
ci ho speso quattro anni.
Esternamente c'è un campo magnetico
che permette di curvare le particelle
e poi ci sono altri strumenti,
che si chiamano calorimetri,
che ad esempio permettono
di vedere gli elettroni,
o i fotoni, o i protoni;
e poi, all'esterno,
c'è il famoso toroide, quello che dà
il nome al nostro esperimento,
che non è altro
che un grosso magnete,
molto grosso, uno dei più grandi
mai costruiti.
All'esterno del toroide
c'è un ulteriore strumento
che ci permette di vedere
una particella che scappa
a tutti gli strati della cipolla
che ha attraversato,
che sono i muoni, che sono
semplicemente dei fratelli
più pesanti degli elettroni.
Ma ora cerchiamo
di rivedere tutto daccapo.
Ecco, questo è il tunnel dell'LHC
a 100 mt di profondità, i protoni
girano all'interno di questi tubi,
attraversano tranquillamente
la frontiera tra Svizzera e Francia,
come faccio io tutte le mattine
per andare a lavorare perché
vivo in Francia e lavoro in Svizzera,
e poi si vanno a scontrare esattamente
lì dove abbiamo costruito
i nostri esperimenti,
esattamente lì dove abbiamo
costruito, ad esempio, ATLAS.
Una nota: si è iniziato
a pensare a questo esperimento
circa negli anni Novanta.
Io ero ancora alle elementari,
e c'era già gente che pensava
all'esperimento sul quale io ho speso
gli ultimi sette anni della mia vita.
Quello che viene fuori dalle collisioni
sono queste tracce colorate,
che abbiamo reso così
per renderle comprensibili a tutti,
è un'immagine grafica
di quello che succede.
In realtà quello che noi vediamo
sono segnali elettrici.
Ogni quanto avviene
uno scontro del genere?
Avviene ogni 50 nanosecondi.
Se volete vederlo in un'altra maniera,
significa che avviene
20 milioni di volte al secondo.
Voi quando andate in vacanza
fate tante fotografie,
tendenzialmente
non 20 milioni al secondo
perché potrebbe essere un po' complicato;
però comunque, per quante ne fate,
voi tornate a casa,
prendete le fotografie e dite:
beh, ma in questa
c'è passata davanti una persona;
questa no, questa è simile all'altra -
e iniziate a buttarne via un po'.
Questo è esattamente
quello che facciamo noi.
Noi abbiamo 20 milioni
di collisioni al secondo,
per 60 secondi in un minuto,
per 60 minuti in un'ora,
per 24 ore al giorno
e circa 200 giorni all'anno,
perché 200 giorni all'anno
sono i giorni in cui noi prendiamo dati.
Di queste 20 milioni
di collisioni al secondo
noi salviamo e teniamo da guardare
soltanto, più o meno,
600 collisioni al secondo.
Perché? Prima di tutto non avremmo
lo spazio per tenere
20 milioni di collisioni
al secondo per tutto l'anno.
In secondo luogo non avremmo
il tempo per guardarle tutte.
Ma la terza cosa, che secondo me
è la più importante,
è il fatto che
la fisica che vogliamo fare,
cioè quello che io
ho iniziato a voler cercare
dal mio corso all'Università,
ad esempio il bosone di Higgs,
capita molto più raramente
di 20 milioni di volte al secondo.
Ad esempio, il bosone di Higgs che decade,
ovvero si trasforma in 4 elettroni,
avviene una volta ogni tre ore.
Capite che non ci servono veramente
20 milioni di eventi al secondo.
Allora vi chiederete: scusa,
ma perché allora non tieni quell'evento
ogni tre ore e butti via gli altri,
perché ne tieni 600 al secondo,
che sono troppi, sono tanti.
Beh, perché comunque
l'obiettivo dell'esperimento
come quello su cui lavoro io
non è soltanto di vedere
il bosone di Higgs,
ma cercare di capire
il più possibile di come
funziona la materia,
di come funziona
la realtà, la natura,
per cui teniamo il più possibile,
ovviamente cose interessanti.
Quello è come si presentano i nostri dati.
Nei nostri dati ci può essere
qualcosa di nuovo e inaspettato,
oppure ci può essere qualcosa
di nuovo e aspettato.
Io, quando ho iniziato
a fare questo esperimento,
speravo che ci fosse il bosone di Higgs,
non lo sapevo ma lo speravo:
e il 4 luglio del 2012,
finalmente abbiamo
annunciato al mondo il fatto
che avevamo trovato il bosone di Higgs.
Questo è Higgs, che si nascondeva
dietro una tenda.
Da quando si nascondeva?
Da circa cinquant'anni,
perché Higgs, Brout ed Englert
hanno postulato l'esistenza
del bosone di Higgs
all'incirca nel 1964.
Perché l'hanno postulato?
Perché il modello che spiegava
come si comportano le particelle
e come queste interagiscono tra di loro
era perfetto, erano le formule matematiche
di cui vi parlavo prima,
funzionava tutto veramente benissimo
ma, secondo questo modello,
le particelle non potevano avere massa;
ma noi abbiamo massa,
le cose che abbiamo davanti hanno massa,
e allora la massa da dove viene?
E questi tre scienziati
hanno postulato l'esistenza
di questa nuova particella,
che era quella che permetteva
alle altre di avere massa.
E per 50 anni l'abbiamo cercato,
e lo abbiamo trovato e un anno
dopo la grande scoperta
hanno pensato bene di dare il premio Nobel
a Englert ed Higgs per aver postulato
l'esistenza del bosone di Higgs.
Ora vi spiego un po' perché,
da quando abbiamo iniziato
a prendere dati con LHC nel 2008,
siamo riusciti a scoprire
il bosone di Higgs soltanto nel 2012.
Com'è che ci avete messo quattro anni?
Il fatto è questo, che -
ad esempio, in questo grafico
voi vedete la massa di quattro leptoni.
Quattro leptoni sono quattro
particelle simili agli elettroni.
Noi, secondo il modello
che conosciamo,
sappiamo che quando abbiamo
una collisione di due protoni
possono essere prodotti
tanti tipi di particelle,
tra cui, forse,
anche il bosone di Higgs.
E ci sono degli scontri
che producono quattro...
.. elettroni, ad esempio;
e lo scontro dei protoni
potrebbe anche produrre
un Higgs che poi si disintegra,
diciamo, decade in quattro elettroni.
Noi quello che conosciamo
è la distribuzione rossa,
cioè noi sappiamo quali sono gli eventi
che finiscono in questa maniera.
I punti neri sono i nostri dati,
per cui noi abbiamo una predizione,
che è quella rossa, e poi andiamo a vedere
veramente i nostri dati,
che sono quelli neri;
e vedete che c'è un buco,
un buco che viene spiegato bene
da quella distribuzione azzurra,
che è la presenza del bosone di Higgs,
per cui attraverso questa immagine
abbiamo capito che il bosone
di Higgs c'era, era lì.
Ok, adesso che sappiamo
che c'è il bosone di Higgs
possiamo chiudere tutto
e andare a casa, abbiamo finito...
No! Io voglio continuare
e tutti noi continuiamo,
perché in realtà
c'è una grande quantità di cose
che ancora, anche se abbiamo visto
il bosone di Higgs,
non conosciamo,
ad esempio la materia oscura.
Ma anche lo stesso bosone
di Higgs necessita di conferme,
perché ad esempio la nostra scoperta
è stata fatta com quattro elettroni.
Io, quello che ho fatto nell'ultimo anno,
diciamo giorno e notte, sabato e domenica,
lavorando abbastanza pesantemente,
è stato coordinare
un gruppo di persone che cercasse
il bosone di Higgs che decade,
cioè si trasforma in due particelle tau,
che sono dei fratelli
ancora più pesanti dell'elettrone;
e dopo un anno di lavoro
siamo riusciti finalmente a trovarle,
e questa è una delle fotografie
dove forse quest'evento
è un Higgs che decade in tau-tau.
Abbiamo annunciato il risultato
10 giorni fa
ed è stata una scoperta fondamentale,
perché questa veramente ci conferma
che il bosone di Higgs che avevamo visto
è quello che ci aspettavamo.
Fare fisica per me
è un'avventura affascinante.
Ha bisogno di musicisti,
ha bisogno di strumenti,
ma ha bisogno di persone
che tutti i giorni si sveglino
ed abbiano voglia di conoscere di più
come funziona la natura.
(Applausi)